[Music]
if you would have asked me two months
ago i would have told you it was
impossible for them to invent something
more boring than my social studies class
turns out i was wrong virtual social
studies on a zoom call with mr hardesty
is even
worse because with the real class i at
least got to see my best friends
sinclair and paj in fact the last time i
saw them in person
was a month ago the day of the protests
ever since then the police have been
vocal that nobody should attempt to
investigate the clown attacks on their
own
so naturally we had a plan to
investigate things on our own
while mr hardesty was droning on about
honestly i didn't even know what
sinclair page and i were chatting in a
separate window on discord
we had a plan to get some information
see while page and i aren't exactly
model students calvin sinclair is kind
of a genius
he'd been doing some of his own research
and was filling us in on his findings
he explained things in our private chat
so i started by pulling as many articles
as i could find
creating a database of all the attacks
from there i mapped everything to get a
visual idea of where these incidents are
happening
i was hoping to find a higher
concentration somewhere and maybe be
able to determine the source
podge asked him if we could see his map
and he sent over an image i opened it up
and immediately saw the pattern the
synapses in my brain were firing off and
i was ready to reveal my discovery no no
of course not
i basically had no idea what i was
looking at what do i look like bill
gates
as far as i could tell it looked like
there were attacks scattered all around
the country
other than the fact that bigger cities
and their suburbs seemed like more
likely targets there was no real pattern
that i could discern
sinclair asked us if we noticed anything
about the map and when we had no idea he
went on to inform us that he had two
major takeaways from it
excuse me who is that who just joined
right now
that was the voice of my teacher mr
hardesty apparently someone had joined
the call
and he was trying to figure out who it
was the person had their camera off and
was making a rather loud sound over the
mic
it sounded like some kind of machine
part or like a camera zooming in and out
the username was just eris i don't know
anyone at our school named eris
and that was the moment i knew we were
being eavesdropped by a clown i grabbed
the nearest weapon i could find it no no
of course not it was obviously one of
those pranks you see online where people
hack into a video conference and create
havoc
i had heard the security on this program
is basically non-existent
but this would have been the first such
intrusion that i had experienced despite
thinking it was a prank there was
something about that noise that i found
kind of creepy
maybe this class was about to actually
be interesting however
after a few minutes of nothing happening
aerys left and i turned my attention
back to our private discord chat
where sinclair would explain his
findings from mapping the data
the first major takeaway was not what i
expected he told us that all of the
attacks had taken place in the u.s
meaning that the clown attacks happening
around the country were probably from an
american organization
the second was more the type of
observation i'd expected him to say
he showed us that all of the points on
the map could be connected by major
highways and provided another graphic
with this linear connection to all the
affected schools not realizing i was
onto something i
told him that it looked like one of
those tour maps you see on a band's
website or at least one of those tour
maps you used to see on banned websites
before
organizers started cancelling all their
tours in fear of being the future
targets of clown lockdowns the situation
had really turned from paranoia to
hysteria when the clown attacks spread
from just happening in classrooms to the
point that they affected
football games stage plays and even
school band concerts which eventually
led
any tours or concerts where kids would
be in attendance to be shut down
sinclair told me he made the same
connection about the map because
of course he did he had already pulled
the data from thousands of tours that
had taken place from 2018
when the attacks started to get bad
until now apparently these ticket broker
websites also did not have the most
secure information
so he was basically able to lay these
tour maps on top of our map and see
which ones looked similar
that narrowed our search down to 97
music acts
16 book tours seven youtuber tour
things 31 comedy shows four traveling
magicians and three
country-wide circus tours furthermore
all three circus tours were put on by
the same company
an operation by the name of park du
soleil apparently that was as much
research as sinclair had time for
but he wanted to share that with us our
obvious next step would be to look into
this park du soleil
i heard the garage door open must have
been my dad getting home
i figured i'd better look like i'm
paying attention to this class when he
gets in here so i minimized our discord
chat and brought back up the zoom watch
the 1975 regulations act was still
effective excuse me
excuse me who is making that sound
it was that zooming sound that we'd
heard earlier the one that was coming
from
the heiress account only that account
was no longer in the call i scanned
through the class on my screen and it
was indicating that the sound was coming
from
calvin sinclair's microphone he was
looking around as if trying to determine
the source of the noise
i saw him typing and heard the familiar
notification sound i flipped back to our
private chat
he was telling us he could hear the
sound in his house now which was kind of
freaking him out
my dad came into the house from the
garage so i switched back to the class
and as i did so i noticed
someone was standing behind sinclair
only
it wasn't a family member at least as
far as i could tell
the person was wearing a yellow clown
suit before i could say
or do anything i saw the clown lower its
head even with sinclair so that it was
in the frame
and we could all see the bionic eye and
robotic jawline that amplified the
already terrifying
appearance of the red and white face
painted nightmare character
i once more heard that unsettling sound
as the bionic eye zoomed back out
since it was now right next to my
friend's head it startled him and he
jumped away from it as he realized how
close the intruder really was
but in that same moment the clown's
robotic jaw opened
and emitted a purple gas substance into
my friend's face which he immediately
started choking on as he fell
out of the frame the entire class was
frozen with shocked looks on their faces
it would have been easy for mr hardesty
to chalk this up to an elaborate prank
but given the climate of recent events
he sat there stunned probably not able
to process what he should say or do
i could feel my heart pounding in my
chest in the short moments that this all
went down
but what would happen next would cause
it to sink into a place in my chest that
i had never
felt it before one more time we all
heard the zoom in sound of the clown's
bionic eye
as it took control of calvin's computer
and furiously typed away
as if it were someone urgently trying to
write down an idea before the moment
passed
his screen then glitched before going
black seeing the look of fear on my
teacher's face
was strangely unsettling maybe it was
the idea that
he's supposed to be an authority figure
and he's supposed to know what to do
when something bad happens
and he didn't or maybe it was the fact
that we were no longer safe anywhere
even inside of our own homes either way
i can never forget the look that he had
the rest of the class was cancelled and
pog and i desperately tried to contact
sinclair to see if he was okay
we mulled over the idea of showing up to
get answers the police had obviously
been called so it seemed like a safe
place to be
but i think we both feared for the worst
we had just about decided on the plan
when i heard something that made me
freeze
i slowly turned in horror to see that
there was someone standing
at my window the same clown that had
attacked sinclair 30 minutes ago was now
coming
after me my head spun and my insides did
somersaults
i realized what must have happened it
was somehow using the computers to find
us in real life
it started when aerys had joined the
zoom call
that's when it found sinclair's location
then it used his computer to get to the
next in line which
may have been me or maybe there was one
before me who even knows at this point
in a panic i fumbled my way out of the
chair knocking it over as i did so
i didn't turn my back on the cyber clown
which caused me to go full horror movie
protagonist and slip and stumble my way
away from the window
but it was also the reason that i was
looking in that direction when
something lashed out from outside the
window frame and struck the clown around
its left eye the non-bionic one
the clown let out an inhuman scream and
fell to the ground
that's when i saw my dad wielding an old
hockey stick from the garage
he whacked the clown several times on
the ground on the third hit
the stick seemed to get caught on
something and stuck in place he tried to
pull it back and finally pulled it hard
enough for the blade to break away from
the handle
we would later find the blade totally
deformed in the yard as if it were a
chewed up toothpick
my dad came back inside and locked us in
the basement as he called the police
we didn't see the cyber clown again the
police showed up collected the evidence
and
that was about it as they were probably
off to go make a report on the next
clown attack
i tried to listen in in the short time
they were there one of them mentioned
something about the mayor planning to
issue a mandatory stay at home order for
all kids
and how that idea wasn't gonna do much
good if the attacks are now happening in
residential neighborhoods
we never found out what happened to
sinclair he's still
missing things have only gotten worse
i talked to pog again tonight he too was
shaken but we both agreed that the
police weren't doing enough
we wanted to continue the investigation
that sinclair started
and that began with looking into the
circus park du soleil
we found out that it was started in the
mid-2000s by a guy named otis park
so that's where our search would have to
begin i haven't seen another clown since
that day
but sometimes in the dead of night
i still think i hear that sound
thanks for listening to all dainty
creepypasta
your total today comes out to 1975. but
if you like this video right now i'll
waive that fee and give you
everything you just listened to
absolutely free
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survived
you